Here's a good one self
that's in Saint Peter's.
And I really liked this one because you
can see the echoes of Jacob's vision for
the establishment of a territory there,
right?
You've got the obelisk in the middle
and then you've got the directions
radiating from the center.
And of course Saint Peters,
this is St Peter's Basilica in Rome,
which is an absolutely unbelievable place.
It's just jaw dropping.
And so there's the cathedral at the back
of it and then there's this circle of
pillars that surrounds it.
You can just see them a little bit on the,
on the middle left there.
That goes all the way around
that entire enclosure.
And uh,
you know,
very large number of
people can gather there.
And then,
so that pillar marks the center and
that'd be the center of Catholicism
essentially.
That's what that represents,
right?
The,
the symbolic center of Catholicism.
Although you could make the case
that the cathedral is the center,
it doesn't really matter.
They're very close together and it's,
it's half a dozen of one
and six or the other.
And then here's another
representation of the same idea,
right?
Is that this is why people don't
like the flag to be burned,
you know,
because conservative people see the flag
as the sacred thing that binds people
together.
And so they're not happy when
that sacred thing is destroyed,
even if it's destroyed
in the name of protest.
Whereas the people who burn flags think,
well,
there are times to dramatize the idea
that the center has been corrupt and you
can demonstrate that by putting it to
the torch in who has a representation
that,
that this,
that the corrupt center now has
to be burned and transformed.
And the thing is they're both right.
They're both right all the time because
the center is absolutely necessary and
is sacred and is almost always also
corrupt and in need of reparation.
That's also an archetipal idea.
And,
and that's a useful thing
to know because you know,
it's easy for young people
in particular to think that,
well,
the world's going to hell in a
handbasket and it's the fault of the last
generation.
They've left us this terrible mass.
And you know,
we've feeling pretty betrayed about that.
Now we have to clean it up.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
People have been thinking
that for like 35,000 years.
It's not new.
And the reason it's not new,
it's cause it's always true.
You know what you're handed
is a sacred center with flaws.
Always.
And it's partly because it's
the creation of the dead,
right in the dead.
Can't see,
and they can't communicate.
And so they're not in
touch with the present.
And so what they've bequeath to you,
apart from the fact that it
might actually be corrupt,
which is a slightly different thing,
is it least blind in dead.
And so what the hell can you expect
from something that's blind and dead?
You know,
you're lucky if it just doesn't
stomp you out of existence.